at the 1939 World's Fair in New York the
exciting new tech was the live
television broadcast Roosevelt became
the first president to address the
nation live on TV but for years leading
up to this event engineers had been
working on one particular technical
problem how do we ensure the audio and
video remain perfectly synced during the
live broadcast without this words and
lip movements wouldn't match up which
would be annoying and distracting for
viewers so how did they do it
well actually they didn't instead they
discovered something pretty incredible
we are not very good at discerning
whether audio and video are in sync for
example I intentionally delayed the
audio of this entire monologue nearly a
tenth of a second and did you notice
I'll clap to make it more obvious the
engineers also found that there's an
asymmetry in our tolerance for this
misalignment we don't really notice if
the sound lags video by up to 125
milliseconds but we can tell something
is wrong if it's leading the video by
more than 45 milliseconds and to
understand why take a look at this
Here I am bouncing a basketball as I
walk away from the camera the sight and
the sound and bounces match up perfectly
but as I walk away you know the sound
will be increasingly delayed due to the
extra time it takes the sound to reach
the camera but the sound still appears
synced this is because your brain is not
reporting to you each instant exactly as
it happens but rather a short interval
of time reorganized to make sense so in
this case your brain automatically
aligns the sound with the site of the
bounce at least up to a point once I'm
over 30 meters away the sound is now
delayed by over a hundred milliseconds
in your brain no longer integrates the
information from your eyes and ears here
let me play the actual sound of the
bounce together with the sound as
received by the camera
this explains why sound can lag video by
more than it can lead I mean imagine you
were at a basketball game and because of
how far away you're sitting the sound is
the lathe your brain can handle that but
if the sound proceeds the site of an
event that would look really odd because
that's something that would never happen
in nature this is why the broadcast
guidelines for acceptable audio and
video mismatches are skewed in favor of
audio lagging behind the video our
brains are good at aligning audio with
the vision that preceded it we can
actually exploit our auto syncing
capabilities to produce some strange
results for example we created this
computer program where when you press
the spacebar a light appears on the
screen but not immediately there is an
80 millisecond delay between the button
push and the light coming on in a study
participants who familiarize themselves
with a similar program came to believe
that the light turned on immediately
after they push the button just as our
brains synchronize the sight and sound
of the basketball bounce press the space
key once to begin this is just the
section where you get the idea of what
it does so you push the spacebar now
watch what happens when you remove the
delay that last one came up without me
even pressing anything you didn't press
anything and it just flashed up there
right some participants were convinced
that the light came on before they
pushed the button they believed that
something else caused the light to come
on even though it was their action that
made it happen this is remarkable
because causality the idea that one
thing leads to another is fundamental
through our understanding of the world
otherwise how would we know who shot
first babies as young as eight months
can demonstrate an understanding of
causality when watching a caregiver wind
a music box if the music stops the
babies touch the caregivers hand to get
the music to start again
causality is something we're hardwired
to recognize but even this core part of
our brains can be fooled and the flash
lag effect gives further insight into
how this happens
stare at the red square in the middle of
the screen and remember what you see
when the flash happens where was the
ring when the flash occurred if you're
like most people you probably saw the
flash in the top half of the ring but
what actually happened was the flash
appeared in the exact center of the Ring
so our perception of the flash seems to
be delayed to explain this result
scientists hypothesized that the brain
was anticipating motion you see the
flash behind the ring because your brain
is predicting where the ring will be not
where it actually is when the flash
happens to test this hypothesis
neuroscientist David Eagleman and his
team modified the experiment so that the
ring reverses direction right at the
moment of the flash now what did you see
if the brain was predicting the motion
of the Ring you should have seen exactly
the same thing as before with the flash
on the top side of the Ring but most
people see it in the bottom half of the
ring how is this possible considering
all the frames leading up to the flash
were exactly the same in both cases if
our brains were anticipating motion then
we would have had to somehow known in
advance that the ring was going to
reverse direction and that seems
impossible so the alternative hypothesis
is that where we see the flash occur
depends on what happens after the flash
there is a delay between the flash
occurring and you perceiving it and the
stuff that happens during that delay is
actually incorporated into your
perception of the event
this is incredibly counterintuitive and
it calls into question our perceptions
of causality the underlying cause of all
of these illusions is the same what we
perceive as the present is not just one
moment but a short interval of time
which is a round of tenth of a second
long now during this period your brain
can perform manipulations that distort
your perception of time and rearrange
causality this interval has been called
the specious present a term coined by a
Robert Kelly all the way back in 1882 he
said all the notes of a bar of a song
seemed to the listener to be contained
in the present all the changes of place
of a meteor seemed to the beholder to be
contained in the
present the present is really a part of
the past a recent past delusive lee
given as being a time that intervenes
between the past and the future
Let It Be Named the specious present why
do we experience time in this illusory
way we feel like we're living in each
instant but what we're actually
experiencing is a short period of time I
think it's not so that our brains can
sync up the sight and sound of distant
events there were so we can watch TV and
movies without distractions
but because fundamentally our brains
need to hold multiple moments at once to
make sense of the world just as you
can't read a book letter by letter you
can't make sense of the world and form
memories instant by instant so we live
in the specious present under the
illusion that we experience each moment
exactly as it happens resource Hey
a lot of the research in this episode
was performed by neuroscientist David
Eagleman and he's actually written a
book entitled the brain the story of you
which includes a lot of details of his
research so if you want to know more
about these topics I highly recommend
you check out his book and in fact you
can download it for free by going to
audible.com/veritasium where this book
is read by David Eagleman himself but if
you're not interested in this one you
can also pick any other book of your
choosing for a one-month free trial
audible is a great audiobook website
with hundreds of thousands of titles in
all areas of literature including
fiction nonfiction and periodicals plus
audible is a longtime supporter of
veritasium so I really want to thank
them for helping me to keep doing what
I'm doing and making these videos and I
want to thank you for watching